hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom live
stream it's been a little while since we
last saw each other so so good to see
you again we have an exciting
conversation today with david siegel
who's a co-chair co-founder of two sigma
which we'll learn more about and also
the the founder and and head of the
siegel family endowment so we're going
to talk a bit about that and uh maybe
most importantly at least from highlands
uh a longtime supporter of all of the
incredible of all the work incredible
supporter of all of the work that we've
been trying to do over the years and
someone who i also consider a close
friend and advisor so i'm very excited
about talking that conversation before
we jump into it i will give my standard
announcements first of all a reminder
that we are not for profit primarily
funded with philanthropic donations so
if you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate also want to give a shout out to
several organizations that stepped up uh
some of them long time supporters some
of them relatively new but when they saw
that especially during the pandemic our
costs had gone up and our usage had gone
up uh special thanks to bank of america
at t google.org novartis fastly and
general motors and of course uh this is
not an exhaustive list of the many many
folks who have been supporting us over
the years and and also through the
pandemic and then last but not least
there's a version of this live stream
that you can get in podcast form
wherever you would get your podcast
homeroom with sal the podcast
so with that very excited
to introduce david siegel
david good to see you
good uh afternoon uh happy to be here
and and there's many things that i want
to talk to you david about uh some of
which we've talked informally about but
i think people are going to be really
interested but i do want to encourage
folks who are listening in especially on
social media put start putting your
questions in the message boards on
youtube and facebook questions about
uh investing questions about the economy
questions about philanthropy and
education these are all of the things
that we will talk about right now
but but david
maybe we'll start with what you know
your quote your day job uh which is
co-running uh um two sigma
can you explain to folks what two sigma
is
uh sure um we we're an investment
management company we like to
say that we're involved with financial
sciences a lot of people say they're a
financial services company
we've kind of coined the expression
financial sciences because we
try
as best as we can to apply the
scientific method
data ai
and
analytical and quantitative methods to
the investment process
a lot of people think of investing as
something that is done you know seat of
the pants that you know you use your
intuition you've got instincts um you
know we've always believed that um you
know applying science to a problem
always gives you a better answer it
really doesn't matter what field that
you're in the application of the
scientific method has really advanced uh
virtually every uh domain uh that we
know of um you know when medicine was
done you know in the dark ages you know
seed of the pants uh you know the
outcomes weren't all that good when the
scientific method was adopted uh and the
field of medicine advanced into
something you know really disciplined uh
then we began to have uh the
breakthroughs that we we have in modern
medicine today
and you know i firmly believe that
investing is the same uh uh story and so
two sigma we really uh you know apply
algorithms data various other let's call
them scientific approaches to try to
drive a better investment outcome
and it's really fascinating because you
know you you have a very deep academic
background and as you know many
academics will tell you uh that markets
are efficient you can't beat the market
you know just modern portfolio theory
just just buy a big basket of things
diversify and just you know let let it
ride so to speak but clearly
you and john overdeck who you founded
two sigma with believe differently and
other people believe differently that no
there there is a science to this that
there actually can be ways to outperform
the markets generally what what gave you
that conviction and i am curious on your
entrepreneurial journey how did you f
how did you fall into this or how did
you make the decision to to start an
investment firm like two sigma
well um you know the statement about the
markets being efficient
is um
uh you know it you know at a high level
it's uh it's true that you know the
markets are pretty efficient uh and uh
you know particularly these days when um
the markets um you know benefit from you
know ready access to lots of information
um and and uh and then the markets you
know there are many different ways to
access the markets you know hundreds of
years ago the markets were not
particularly efficient because you know
people had advantages on information
people didn't even you know very few
people had access to the markets so you
know the world is moving in a direction
that is making the markets more
efficient but they're not perfectly
efficient uh so i think you know when
people do make the statements that the
markets are efficient i think really
what they're saying is they're pretty
efficient so what that means is that
it's actually a little bit more
difficult than you might think to
actually outperform the markets but that
doesn't mean it's impossible to so the
question that you have is if you have a
belief that you're going to be able to
outperform you know an index like the s
p 500 um you know what would your uh uh
your your some people would call it your
advantage be you know what what why do
you think you know what do you have
access to that would give you the
ability to do that and you know one um
uh you know our answer would be well
we're going to be very scientific about
it we're going to use a lot of data
uh and you know we're going to look at
the markets and you know primarily using
a lot of computer algorithms in a way
that it's hard for
uh you know sort of the old-fashioned
very gut instinct based approach to
compete with so that would that's the
reason that we believe that um despite
the fact that the markets are pretty
efficient that you know we can do better
and when when y'all were starting the
firm you know
you do have you did have bra
you did have experience working at
previous firms like this was it was it's
like you know i i think we could do
better i think we can do better than the
state of the art that's out there and
i'm curious how do you do you and john
have some initial algorithms that you
had back tested and you know for those
who don't know back testing is hey we
have a theory we have an algorithm let's
take this algorithm on historic data and
see how it would have performed and
you're like yeah i think we got
something interesting here how did you
how did it start i'm always curious
about that that that phase of an
organization no it wasn't like that it
was more just a uh you know it's like
any uh entrepreneurial uh
uh uh exercise i think that people just
have a belief and a conviction and so
you just uh
you know
you know we we started with a blank
sheet of paper but just you know
literally a belief that this is the
future and you know this is more
different than i think uh virtually all
tech startups uh you know most of the
successful companies that you have today
uh that have emerged out of silicon
valley and elsewhere you know they've
often just started with a belief that
you know this is how
uh you know we can do better and uh you
know so
really just a belief
yeah and that that belief uh has been
validated um
i am curious i mean as someone who has
who studies markets with a scientific
lens as you mentioned
you know what one there's been a lot of
talk
about a k-shaped recovery about some
people are doing just fine other people
are doing less fine even before the
pandemic people have been talking about
how automation and technology they're
going to benefit some folks but they
could hurt other other folks i know this
is an area that you've thought deeply
about and obviously you're you're in it
uh in in certain ways
where do you think we're heading from an
economic point of view what do you think
the impacts of the pandemic are what do
you think is going on in markets right
now and what do you think we need to be
hopeful for or watch out for a little
bit longer term
well you know these are really going to
be just my personal views not uh not of
of the company uh uh you know i just
want to be clear this isn't the kind of
thing that the company that uh you know
these are not exactly the kind of uh
investment approaches the firm takes so
speaking really just entirely personally
uh and uh you know this is is i don't
think um
actually uh a new trend uh in america it
really does appear that our economy uh
has been moving in a direction where
certain people are doing
uh you know better and better and uh
other people
are falling behind and uh you know i
think that this accelerated during the
pandemic uh for you know a number of
reasons i can really quickly go into
them and we can talk about this for
hours and hours but
um i think a lot of the uh bifurcation
of economic outcomes are being caused by
fundamental changes in our economy that
are driven by technology um
you know the rapid transformation of the
global economy you know uh
because of technological innovation uh
the internet um you know you know you
you know we you're all familiar with uh
you know obviously google and uber and
you know there are dozens of companies
that you know are virtually brand new
and you know amazon these firms have
changed the way all aspects of our
economy function and when you have a big
economic uh dislocation occurring driven
by technological change that is going to
uh you know restack the deck the people
that benefit will be different than the
people that benefited before
uh other people who thought that they
had stability in their work will find
that they no longer have stability the
kind of skills that you need to get
ahead change you know everyone knows
today that technical skills are more
valuable than they were
you know ever before
people that have mastered uh
certain kinds of technologies and you
know ai is one of them have you know you
know had you know unlimited opportunity
in the new economy people with um uh you
know certain other kinds of skill sets
where automation has taken over
have been falling behind and this trend
accelerated during the pandemic in part
because uh
people were investing firms were
investing very heavily in you know more
automation
looking at more ways to reduce
dependence on you know traditional
human-based approaches for doing things
so you know this is one of the many
factors that are driving uh you know a
you know what i would call an alarming
uh
uh
change in our economy which uh you know
we have to as society we need to address
and do you think this is something
different about what we're going through
now versus
previous periods of technological change
obviously people talk about the
industrial revolution and yes people who
are driving uh horse carriages or i
guess even the horses themselves i guess
horses probably did lose a lot of work
during the during just the automation
with cars but a lot of people point to
that and say well you know yes a lot of
there was a lot of flux a lot of change
in things but um at the same time
overall jobs were created there was a
broad-based middle class that came out
of the industrial revolution so this
revolution might not be
any different it could be change but
overall it'll be better but then you
hear on the other side people say well i
don't know artificial intelligence
automation they're kind of getting
deeper into what human beings are
oftentimes capable of um where do you
fall on that debate
well uh you know
again a
very complicated question try to give up
over probably over simple
uh simplified answer but um i i i do not
believe that there will be a lack of
jobs
um there is plenty of work that only uh
humans can do
and uh as we uh automate certain kinds
of work and you know we're freeing up
people to do other kinds of work and um
you know we have an aging population
there's going to be a need for more
people just as one example
more people to take care of of the
elderly um there is crumbling
infrastructure all around america we
need more people to rebuild this uh you
know the robots are not going to be
handling this kind of work um people
have now changed their shopping habits
we need more people to deliver all the
packages uh you know it's unlikely that
we're gonna have uh you know despite all
the hype i don't think drones are gonna
be
really uh changing how we get deliveries
uh
you know anytime soon so the amount of
work for people to do it's not going
away um but the problem is that uh
you know we have to have an adjustment
here and we have to decide if if we're
going to be you know able to pay
middle-class wages for the new kind of
work
and you know it is possible that uh you
know a lot of the new work people are
only going to want to pay relatively low
wages for
and maybe these workers won't have the
ability to uh in any way organized to
get higher wages so you might end up
with a relatively uh you know large
amount of work at wages that are you
know not really suitable for middle
class living
um
now uh you know the previous the
industrial revolution which is has been
well studied of course the outcome was a
uh a vibrant thriving middle class but
you know you have to remember that the
transition from say the beginning of the
industrial revolution
to uh the thriving middle class you know
also uh brought with it you know world
war one world war ii
there was a lot of trouble there was a
depression in there so it wasn't really
a smooth transition but eventually you
got to a spot that was actually pretty
good
the goal here is to make sure that we
don't have a bumpy ride uh certainly we
don't want to repeat anything like that
when we go to you know this
this new economic phase that is being
you know heavily driven by a new wave of
technology
yeah no it's a really good point and you
know oftentimes the economics and the
the history of things like wars and and
oftentimes get disjointed but they are
connected in probably more ways than
even the the history books uh try to
draw draw connections i mean what what
do you think you know just stay on this
this question and i'm getting a lot of
questions from i'm assuming young people
on you know what advice would you have
for them you know given the the world
that we're we're going into and all that
so i'll it'll be a double question what
advice do you have for them as
individuals but also what advice do you
are you thinking about for society i
know you've thought and you've written
about some of this you know what's the
role of government with the
not-for-profit sector the for-profit
sector
how do you think about this
oh
well uh
you know
government
you know again
saul every question give me an easy
question the the you know the role of
government is obviously incredibly
important in society uh you know i think
people uh in many in my own personal
views people essentially take
government for granted uh
because in many cases what the
government is doing is
providing infrastructure they're
providing things that are kind of behind
the scenes and then all the excitement
that the infrastructure the government
provides uh then leads to the vibrant
economy and the good outcomes so you
know the private sector is built upon
the foundation that the government has
created and you know when i'm talking
about infra infrastructure i'm using a
very broad definition uh you know the
government you know in many cases is
involved with physical infrastructure
like roads and bridges and tunnels and
the government may very well be involved
with more modern infrastructure uh as
well you know either directly or
indirectly through policy decisions the
government is obviously involved with
education the government government is
involved with the rule of law creating
an environment where businesses can
thrive uh
you know there is no such thing by the
way as uh capitalism without uh
government intervention you know the
economy is you know all economies the us
and every country in the world um
they're you know they're not just you
know the private sector without any
rules the government creates rules of
the road and so this infrastructure very
broadly is critical for a thriving
uh
not only economy but just for people to
live good lives and and so i think that
you know government well-functioning
government is incredibly important
and what's your what's your what's your
advice and i mean yeah there's a lot
that we could talk for hours just on the
government piece or the the for profit
and we'll talk about philanthropy in a
second but on the question of
individuals you know for a lot of the
young people who are asking questions
like what should i do with my life
people like should i go into computer
science how should i do it how should i
navigate you know what's your message
for folks um how they should be thinking
about their life given
what is what seems like likely to happen
the the cross currents of technology and
the economy and all of that
well you know
you know first and foremost i would
start by uh telling people that you know
they really need to
to to pursue their passions um there's
no right answer uh like if i were to say
yeah the right thing to do is you know
become a you know ai specialist um now
sure that there's gonna be a lot of
opportunity for such people but that is
not going to necessarily be interesting
to uh everyone um so i think the key
thing is that you know in today's world
uh you know look it is you know
it's a relatively tough world uh you
know people are struggling to find their
way in our economy because it's changing
very quickly and the skills that people
need are not obvious but i think you
know the thing that's most important
is you know to have a passion for what
you're doing and if it's something that
you really want to do
uh it's much more likely that you will
um you know put the energy into it to
of course is success stem skills are
more important you know you should
really get your basic math skills down
you know you should spend time on the
khan academy to perfect uh hear the
material that uh that that wonderful
organization has put together but i
would definitely vote for
you you got to be pursuing something
that you re that that brings you joy uh
your life will be better uh you know
don't pursue something simply because
you read somewhere that it's going to be
the courier of the future and it's very
hard to predict the future so you you
you know you might end up getting that
totally wrong another thing i would
mention is that um uh you know the world
is changing very quickly and what this
means is that you're gonna have to
really become uh you know a constant
lifelong learner and and so whatever you
know your interests are today whatever
the skills that you develop through your
uh education today um keep in mind that
you're going to have to continue to
invest
to make sure that you know you're ready
for for the next curveball that our
vibrant world is going to throw at you
so this again uh points to trying to go
in a direction where you have a passion
it's kind of hard to force yourself to
continue to
uh improve and and gain new skills in
something that you don't like at all so
passion passion passion
i couldn't agree with that more and it's
funny because you know i remember when i
was a kid and i had i had i didn't have
a passion for math and for science and
and for things like that and for
computers but i also had a passion for
for art and drawing and you know the
message that i got oftentimes is you
know first generation immigrant family
like
that's not going to be practical sal
that's a nice hobby but you know you
fast forward today and you see that wow
you know fields like design are actually
highly sought after uh
and and can be very pragmatic and and
you can do very very well in them and
that even even you know my own journey
um
you know i used to be in a at least a
tangential field to yours we were a
different type of investment firm but we
were in markets and things and i enjoyed
that and i had a passion for it but i
had this even deeper passion for
education and that if you just create a
little bit of space for it you know
we're in a brave new world where
opportunity no one could have predicted
the job that i have
or even the type of organization so i
think that's really good advice is that
the combination of having really strong
skills probably anything that you want
to do at some form of reasonable scale
and impact will involve some type of
technology but then you couple that with
your passions
and you you can be quite formidable
um what what what you know moving on to
the the
another big piece of your life which is
philanthropy and as i mentioned i'm very
biased because uh actually both you and
john have been great supporters of of
kai and your families have been great
supporters of khan academy over the
years but what got you into philanthropy
arguably at a relatively young age a lot
of people go through their
their stage where they're kind of
earning and then later in life they
start going into philanthropy what got
you into it why did you prioritize it
and how do you what's your framework of
philanthropy where do you think that you
can make the biggest difference
well
i i
you know
the
journey that i took into philanthropy
started a long time ago
you know
doing things to help people has uh
always
you know
it you know we all have to do that it
you know i think that everyone in
society has
some uh obligation i mean some people
say you should uh you know if everyone
you know gives back a little bit more
than they take uh the world would be you
know forever a better place and and so
if you think just logically uh uh uh
you you know
how did you get to where you are how did
i get to where i am i was you know uh
benefiting from essentially
uh uh all kinds of philanthropic
things over my lifetime education in
america
you know is largely supported with
philanthropy i got a really good
education uh
everywhere i look i'm the beneficiary of
other people who decided that they
wanted to give back to society and that
made me uh recognize at a relatively
early age that you know i want to do the
same thing
and also you know as you start to do
philanthropic things it makes you
actually want to do more uh you know so
i find philanthropy to be you know in a
way addictive um you know you get your
feet wet you get involved with an
organization you help them you know you
you give with your heart you give a
little bit from your checkbook checkbook
whatever you can do and then i think
virtually everyone concludes wow that
felt great
and um and you know it's so easy to get
involved with philanthropy because their
needs everywhere and so you know i
started in a small way
and uh
my own journey was well you know how can
i apply
uh what i know
uh you know what what are the you know
special things that i might be able to
do
to help and
and uh you know one the area that i
ended up focusing on and that my uh
the siegel family endowment focuses on
is essentially uh to help people
in the the journey through tech the
technological change that our society is
going through how are we going to
prepare
and help people navigate and
increasingly technical and
technologically driven society and these
changes that are occurring you know as
we've talked about actually earlier in
in this uh call saul uh you know are
are very very challenging for for
individuals for institutions for
governments uh this technological
transformation is something that you
know i think that um
you know my foundation can help uh uh
you know improve the outcomes a little
bit um and and that's what we're really
committed to to be focused on
and and i'm getting a ton of questions a
question related to that from catherine
marchand uh from facebook
what are your suggestions for teaching
young children how to be responsible
philanthropists guidance for giving
please and i'll expand her question
what's your advice for philanthropists
in general because
you know philanthropy doesn't always
have the same type of objective function
that you can get in the investing world
of the for-profit world where you can
say oh i put this much money in and i
got this much money back in philanthropy
you're putting some dollars and
potentially time and effort and energy
in
and there is a return and impact but but
how do you think about that and how do
you what advice you have for people
with children or or other
philanthropists like yourself to do it
well
well i you know first of all i i i
i you know particularly for younger
folks you know i would put
you know a little more of the emphasis
on time rather than dollars um because
you see you know just um you know making
a donation to an organization uh
you know
it's wonderful you should do that uh you
know as sal mentioned uh the the khan
academy has a donate page and i think
everyone now should click over there but
there's something even
i think more transformative if you
actually put your time into it and
putting your time into it will actually
make you more likely to want to put your
dollars into it and
and uh
you know young kids generally have more
time than dollars and
uh and so i think that there's an
opportunity
to
to to uh
get
the youth involved
with um
philanthropy by picking community
service activities in fact by the way i
think that there's a big argument
that um you know in america we would
benefit by
having far more involvement of young
kids in community service uh i think
that
uh this would actually in general make a
more cohesive society so my
my
recommendation would really be you know
to to pick philanthropic community
service uh activities and i think as a
great introduction you know you do it
close to home uh because then you can
see the impact of what you're doing it
can be much more direct and then this
will i think convince even young people
about how incredibly wonderful
philanthropy really is because you you
can just see that your time and your
efforts really made something better
yeah couldn't couldn't agree more and i
actually think there's tons of people
who want to provide them they see more
outlets i will put a plug for another
related not-for-profit schoolhouse.world
where folks listening they can tutor
give their time but you really are
giving resources there your your time
has a lot of value that you can you can
give to other people i couldn't agree
with with you more david you know these
conversations are all these fun
conversations always go way faster than
i expected so maybe i'll just i'll just
finish with one kind of big question
you know you clearly are already doing
many many big things and have already
done many big things but when you look
at your next five years 10 years 20
years
what do you
what do you hope to be the impact what
what do you want the world to look like
based on work that you're doing maybe in
collaboration with others
well
funny enough
just this morning i was meeting with
some people from my foundation talking
about that very question uh maybe they
mentioned that too
uh no you know we're just linked
technically i did not know that
yeah some kind of uh you know
quantum effect um the
sol that's a really uh actually the
hardest question yet um
i really uh don't know i think that
um
i
you know the thing that uh
you know i'm learning over time is that
um you know really you got to live
you know
you're the amount of the most valuable
thing i've got left is my time and i
have to be very careful of what i focus
on
and i have to also be realistic about
what i can accomplish um you know i
think that um
uh you know over the coming uh decades
what i would really like to be able to
do
is to um impact um you know a broad
range of uh i would like to make our
society and this is really why the
mission of the foundation really is
about the impact of technology on
society i would like to make our society
be one that is more uh fair that um is
more inclusive that has better outcomes
for a broader set of people um i think
that uh
you know you know if we all look back
maybe 20 or 30 years from now i think
we'll all be incredibly happy
if
um you know we uh we can all say that
you know over the last couple of decades
you know america and the world uh was
able to deliver good outcomes for you
know a diverse set of people that we
were able to to to bring to the world uh
you know the the kind of equity that in
the past hasn't existed so i'd like to
be able to make an impact there
no those are inspiring words and i think
and i think we're worth worth pursuing
well david thank you so much for the
time thank you
you your family i mean for just being
long time
supporters of of not just resources but
your time your advice as i mentioned i
consider you a close advisor on on all
things we're we're up to so so thank you
for so much for being for joining us but
even more important for being part of uh
of our journey here at khan academy
solid was my pleasure really happy to be
here today thank you
thank you
well thanks everyone for joining um i
got to tell you you know david is
someone i could speak to for hours and
sometimes we have uh about about
everything from investing to the economy
to philanthropy and and we have a lot of
similar interests uh uh so so anyway
thanks for joining this conversation i
really appreciate your questions i'm
sorry i couldn't get to all of them uh
but i i look forward to our next
homeroom with sal see you then onward
you